gibt immer das ding hier herzlich
[Musik]
willkommen bei einem video sprechen wir
sind wieder wie in meiner letzten
position
ich habe mir für heute wir was komplett
gestört ist einfallen lassen
ich weiß gar nicht was ich sagen soll am
anfang auf jeden fall bekommen sofort
auf den punkt heute haben schon gedacht
es gibt ja echt keine sachen zum essen
oder gäste so normale dinge die man so
mittags und abends ist wie zum beispiel
mal gewitzt oder einen burger und dann
gibts auch dinge die man eigentlich
nicht normalerweise wie zb pizza burger
aus gummi einfach so süßigkeiten gummi
wie nennt man das dem ja einfach also
gummi essens sachen die man halt essen
kann okay leute jetzt teilt euch also
sehr interessant ich weiß eigentlich gar
nicht kennt die nacht aber jetzt leute
passt auch besser im alter wtf web de
facto mein gott was soll das sein genau
das ist eine trommel aus gummi dann
haben wir hier eine pizza und ich hoffe
frage könnt ihr euch selbst zu antworten
eine pizza aus ja und wir haben hier
eine pizza irgendwie habe ich mich an
getäuscht und leute hier haben wir nazis
auto und jetzt das gratis denn mein
absoluter favorit von freixenet ein
fucking burger aus
ich bin so gespannt wieder schmecken
will von dem video ist eigentlich ganz
einfach ich probiere er dass normale
hätten also die normale pizza und danach
die gummi pizza und stellen klein
vergleiche erwachsenen wirklich auf die
wirklichkeit besser schmeckt oder ob man
auch mal so eine gummi väter zur
abwechslung essen kann ich
glücklicherweise trocken jetzt wirklich
das ganze mache ich halt
damit einen satten und ms gesetzlich so
viel zeit fand auch aus gummi gibt
deswegen wenn ich das noch mal machen
soll wenn sich gefällt dann macht man
nach oben ich bin mehr gespannt bei
12.000 leichtsinnig ist eine tolle marke
probiere ich dann mal die nächsten
sachen auch gemessen ja was jetzt für
dich sein gelangen gar nicht lange durch
mit der pizza anfang
ich fange ich kann mir kommen kann oder
zirkus erwartet so das sind die nämlich
ganz spezielle bommel okay leute
empfangen
früher waren die leute warten mal guck
mal hier
wie unterschiedlich kann die eigentliche
auftrag oder war es schon richtig
aufpassen dass hier so leute
wir probieren das ganze jetzt mal ich
fange einfach mal ganz normal mit einer
bubi pommes an
[Musik]
schon gut findet mein okay was haben wir
hier haben wir ketchup deutschland
einfach kreisstruktur schützen
ich habe ist kokosnuss zwar gar nicht
also da kann ich echt zu sagen egal ob
jetzt als kleiner snack den
kindergeburtstag oder so sind normale
kommen wirklich immer besser okay leute
stellen wir das erstmal schon zur seite
wir machen weiter und war jetzt wird
knapp
erst mal wieder die ganz normale nicht
weiter wien abschluss merken schon mal
probiert weil falsche leute gegen die
nazis aus gummi
[Musik]
das weckt halt wieder selbst berger
weist das gummi bürger genauso schmeckt
s nicht eins zu eins nicht mein
geschmack präferiert auch absolut zu den
normalen apfel stirbt also wie kann man
sich auf jeden fall mal gönnen
einzig das 2 0 für normal
wir hätten da machen und jetzt kommen
wir zu meiner beiden favoriten und war
zudem burger ist sogar noch ein bisschen
warm werden nachdem gestellt ich bin ein
richtiger schock
wir können ja mal kurz gucken was ist
denn hier so drauf doch hier also ganz
normal tomaten salatgurken und so weiter
das ist der bürger und der soll den
kleinen erreichen ware ausgeliefert das
ist nichts fix eltingen leute
dreimal die immer mal mit dem ding hier
an
[Musik]
ich habe auf jeden fall schon bessere
bürger aber jetzt junge wert die zellen
eingepackt war der richtig geil
zigmal fenster fällt auseinander wenn es
passiert auch mal eine gibt immer das
ding hier hinter heftig oder ok bis 3
[Musik]
ich glaub ich bekam fünf minuten muss
das kleine im top leute was die berge
angeht das tackling unterberger da
präparieren texte diesem gummihaut mir
der mittlerweile auseinandergefallen
einzig kommt natürlich auf die tageszeit
an wenn man mal von gummi berger aber
das kann man auf jeden fall mehr gut
verschenken an gummi berger keine ahnung
wie haben denn jetzt aus der innenstadt
ihren aber da gibt's mehrere läden mit
der kugel miteinander aber schmeckt mega
gut kann man echt mal probieren so die
bekannten verschiedenen geschmäcker
zusammen deswegen würde ich mal sagen
kommen 2 1 für normale leute und jetzt
bitte kurz ein traum was soll ich mit
dem nassen strecke zu machen
so leute und jetzt kurzen trommelwirbel
jetzt probiere einfach mal hier die
bitter gegen und jetzt stecken immer
hier die plätze auf jeden fall bin ich
mir ja gespannt wir haben nicht einmal
die ganz normale peter die haben sich
sogar schon geschnitten trainer hier die
gummi pizza was sie braucht eigentlich
mehr in der interviewten also pizza
weiter jeder die pizza schmeckt
[Musik]
was denken die leute nicht dabei ach
komm wir machen jetzt meine pizza aus
gummi ja ein bisschen hier waren bisher
mir von einem glatt zusammen und kreis
auch das ist das einzige was für
entwickler ist dürfte untendrunter
kriegt aber es tut
probier's einfach mal hier den teil
davon hier guckt euch das mal an das ist
ja eine sowie tolle kleine pfütze
einfach gut aber vom geschmack her geht
dass die alterung für eine gleiche
richtung nicht er vor und rät ihr
auseinander einige kameras der männer
pitzer leute was soll ich dazu sagen
ganz klar eigentlich hier auch um 321 in
ganz klarer sieg für die normalen essen
flachen also kauft euch auf jeden fall
niemals so ein zeug hier ist sei denn
gefeierten geburtstag oder so dann kann
man es auf jeden fall noch ein anderes
ich sagen das was sie denn notwendig
gefallen hat dann lass uns doch nach
oben schon gesagt beim workshop life
gibt am zweiten tag und da habe ich auch
schon wo andere sachen gewöhnt ich zum
beispiel durch die wir eine wirklich
richtig fette trasse und ja das war ich
etwas drauf das sicher anders würde ich
sagen kommt dann sind seine nach oben
die und abgeschleppt wird bis 17 uhr und
wir sehen uns morgen wieder morgen um
38,3 und wünsche eine angenehm sagt und
peace das war's